well my story is about award-winning
actress cicely tyson who is starring
countless films
tv shows and broadway plays they include
roots remember that
trip to bountiful i saw that the
autobiography of miss jane pittman i
watched it again over the weekend
and now in a new memoir out today it's
called look at this cover guys just
as i am i love this picture of her the
96 year old tyson is opening up about
her very impressive career and her
personal life
so we met her in harlem at the
abyssinian baptist church that was her
home church before the pandemic
and she talks to us about her legendary
career her love life it's a doozy
and her process behind choosing roles
[Music]
whenever i'm offered a script what i'm
interested in when i get it
is why me who was that character
and why did they want me to play it
and when i get to the point where i feel
like her skin has fitted my
arm or my mind
then i know there's something about her
it was a little girl what
what were your dreams i was a very shy
child
if you got 15 minutes of birds out of me
you got plenty
you know i was a thinker i sucked this
finger until i was 12 years old that's
why i have these [ __ ] teeth
born in 1924 to west indian parents
cicely tyson recounts her extraordinary
life in her new memoir
just as i am i am an observer of human
nature
and the dream of audacious dreams the
journey to stardom was not an easy one
for tyson
who became pregnant when she was 17 and
had a short marriage that lasted just
over two years
tyson began her acting career as a
single mother a choice that brought
conflict at home
weren't you surprised hisley that your
mother actually kicked you out of the
house because you wanted to be in here
yes
oh she told me i couldn't live there and
do that
suddenly i found something that i loved
to do
and i had a child to support
so you weren't thinking when i grow up i
want to be an actress no
my mother i don't know what she wanted
me to be
she thought that i was going to live
in the den of iniquity
because we grew up in the slums
okay lots of prostitutes walking up and
down the street
and that's all she knew about movies her
mother
eventually came around and their
connection is a strong one to this day
especially in this church and i feel
that her spirit is here
and so i bought this pew in her name so
this was a way to honor her that's right
tyson made her on-screen debut at 31 in
the 1956 film carob goal
shortly after that she enrolled in an
acting school run by paul mann
a well-known acting coach she found
herself alone with him after her first
class
and she writes about a traumatic
encounter he said excuse me
miss tyson i'd like to talk to you
so i turned around and came back and
before i know it he
pulled me down and he was touching you
and groping yes
no what he wanted me to do was something
worse than that
i thought about the whole incident
when i got home and um
you know i never said a chair about that
until this moment
all these years later it still affects
you that way
um the whole thought that you could go
out
innocently to achieve something
and it turns out to be something so
vulgar and coarse and
demeaning to you as a young black woman
but i made up my mind then that i went
there for a reason
and that reason had not changed it
sounds like a me too incident before we
were even calling it me too
and some people would say but why did
you go back and to that you say
i went back to get what i
was told i needed in order to achieve
what i wanted and i think of the many
young black women who go through that
and are devastated by it and it kills
their dream i was not going to let that
happen to me
through her sheer determination her
talent blossomed and landed tyson
the headlining role of rebecca and
sounder you've got you a low-life job mr
sheriff
the 1972 film about a black sharecropper
family
and a conversation with a white
journalist about the movie
pushed tyson to find new purpose in her
calling
so you're promoting sounder a reporter
said to you that he felt
a bit of bigotry in himself while he was
watching the movie
when i asked him why so he said
i was uncomfortable about your older son
referring to his father as daddy
i said do you have children what do they
call
you he said they called me daddy
and i thought my god
this man is thinking
that we're not human beings and i made
up my mind
that i could not afford
the luxury of just being an
actress and that i would use my career
as my platform namely you want black
people to be seen as human beings
that's right after playing over a
hundred roles on the stage and screen
tyson has won three emmys a tony and an
oscar this is the culmination of all
those
years of have and have nots
but beyond her public success her memoir
documents her love story with jazz icon
miles davis
[Music]
they were married for seven years but
their romance spanned decades
friends always wondered why in the world
are you with miles davis because you're
right
he was unfaithful he was abusive
you said myles needed to be saved
from himself and you needed someone to
save
well listen people who hurt it's
always the person that is closest to
them
that they hurt and i was in love with
him
he was a beautiful human being but you
know what on his deathbed
he wanted you to know that he was
sorry tell cecily i'm sorry
was he the love of your life yes
but did you think you could never find
love like that again
i haven't you haven't have you been
looking no
[Laughter]
i'll ask you this what does it feel like
to be 96 and a legend
miss legend i'm amazed every single day
i live
do you feel like you have more to do yes
that's why i'm still here
i mean what my life became is not what i
expected
i had no idea that i would touch anybody
when the time comes what do you want us
to remember about you
[Music]
i've done my best
i just adore her she really is royalty
to me and it was so i could have talked
to her all afternoon
when we talked about miles i loved this
she said hostility
and devotion can live side by side i
love that
sometimes love is not always born of
logic and when i said you know what do
you really need what do people need she
said well i will talk as a black woman
you need cayenne pepper a stash of cash
and a quiet place yeah she's happy to
say that she has
all three yeah she's in and maya she's
always had incredible dignity
and resilience and you've always felt it
whenever she spoke she has and you know
she said i grew up you know people
calling me nappy-headed and
shy and withdrawn but now you know you
see her she's very beautiful she's regal
she said early on in her career they
told her that she should get braces for
the teeth she says are bucked and she
said no
i like how i look yeah she has such a
deliberate and powerful way of speaking
this word is just set down like a
sidewalk and you come to the end and
it's gorgeous
there's so many ways to take inspiration
from her life but i i'm surprised that
she was shy
yeah she found acting as a way to speak
through others that's a gorgeous idea
yeah she
she will say i'm still kind of shy i go
no you're not she goes no actually i am
i spend a lot of time by myself she has
a small circle of friends
tyler perry is a very good friend of
hers i meant to say to tyler tyler's in
the book she calls tyler one of her
jewels so she has a small group of
friends and she keeps very close
oh and i said do you want another role
she goes yes you know
somebody approaches me about a role yes
it's better than sitting at home making
butt prints
i love that
we all need to follow